dr. Hotez let me cut to the chase every
article says don't panic we are how do
we can't contain our ancient worry about
these viruses well it is a scary disease
that has a high lethality we all know
that but we have to remember the
situation that we have in the United
States is so different from what we're
seeing in Liberia and Guinea and Sierra
Leone this is a virus that is actually
not very easily transmissible we have a
healthcare infrastructure in the United
States and the risk of an epidemic
occurring like we're seeing in West
Africa is practically zero what would
you like from the government I think of
your work in biochemistry molecular
biology Weill Cornell Mass General
Hospital you've seen every institution
what is your wish list from the
government well I think right now what
we have to put a lot of emphasis on in
order to contain the epidemic in West
Africa is to get new drugs new vaccines
out there as quickly as we can you know
this evolves of neglected tropical
disease we make vaccines for neglected
tropical diseases our technology our
ability to make these products is
outpaced our social and political
institutions to actually get them
developed and get out there so we really
have to accelerate their development as
you know I think of the history of
penicillin and the ramp-up that we saw
in antibiotics how close are we to a
broad distribution of therapy for
western Africa so that's a great
question and that's what the question
everybody wants to really know of what
we've got is a very promising drug
that's being produced by the chemical
subsidiary of Fujifilm in Japan is
called favour para ver we already know
it's safe in human trials that were
conducted for another virus influenza
it has great activity against Ebola and
animals I think the company says it has
20,000 doses ready to ship out I think
that's when we have to move on very
quickly we also have too promising of
two or three promising vaccines the one
I think first out of the gate is one by
GlaxoSmithKline and the NIH and I think
we've got a move on that
as well dr. Hotez again speaking as a
doctor can you help us understand what
makes the protein of Ebola so difficult
to block well it's actually not that
difficult a target in the laboratory and
that's why I think we have a lot of new
promising products the problem is
there's no commercial market for these
diseases like neglected tropical
diseases because and so the major
pharmaceutical companies have not had
the incentive to actually develop them
so the technology is there we just have
to put the funding in and and now
introduce these products into Liberia
and Guinea and Sierra Leone and that's
not easy because it's a very chaotic
situation right now and that's why I'm
so excited to know that President Obama
sent in 3,000 troops to create some
semblance of a healthcare infrastructure
it makes it possible not to introduce
these new products the heart of the
matter is is these are societies they
don't have the infrastructure to begin
to contain the virus how close are we to
an epidemic well we're we're in an
epidemic situation already in West
Africa remember these are these three
countries that are affected Liberia
Sierra Leone and Guinea have only
recently emerged out of really horrific
war horrific civil conflict with
terrible atrocities and the first thing
that suffers is healthcare
infrastructure you know when we talk
about that these are neglected tropical
diseases the tropical parts of misnomer
these are diseases of poverty and
conflict you show me poverty and
conflict or a post-conflict situation
I'll show you these diseases Peter Hotez
thank you so much honored to have you
with us today he is at Baylor University
and their National School of Tropical
Medicine